- [Announcer] Please,
give a warm, warm welcome
and big applause to the one
and only Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applauds)
Welcome.
- Hey brother.
- Take it away.
- Morning.
- Jan, hit the stage.
- Good morning Helsinki,
thanks for having me.
I'm gonna introduce Jan,
one of the co-founders
of this event.
Let's bring up the chair.
Do you guys have the video prompted?
- I hope we do.
- So before--
- Good morning, everyone.
- Before we go into our keynote,
we have a bet to settle
that we created a couple of months ago.
And there's some video footage for context
for this audience.
I'm awfully excited about what
I get to do in a little bit.
Do they have the video,
'cause I'd love to play it.
- [Jan] Yes, we have the video.
Could you roll the Finland video?
- Oh, this is gonna be good.
- All right.
- [Gary] How much would it
cost you to shave your head?
No no, shave the head.
Shave your head, I mean,
that's an interesting one.
You're fine.
What about you?
- I'm cheap.
- How much?
- So how much?
- A hundred dollars.
- [Gary] This is Jan and I in
Sweden and I was asking people
how much it would cost to shave their head
and Jan said all he needed was $100.
Where's Baben?
Get on it.
We're doing this, it's a 100%
blog, we're shaving his head
for a hundred dollars.
(Baben speaks indistinctly)
Oh, even better.
So, this is Baben, one of my video guys
and he's now running around trying to find
(chuckles)
a razor.
- [Baben] How's it going?
Do you guys have razors, like,
if, in theory, I needed
to cut my hair off?
- [Jan] In theory.
(chuckles)
- [Gary] In theory, to cut people's...
- [Jan] But we all--
- Blog, I'm very upset, Baben has failed.
Leb, one, Baben, zero.
We are very fortunate or unfortunate--
- Unfortunate, I want to do
it for Finland, you know.
One hundred, one hundred, boom.
- We should shave a hundred in his head.
How much would it cost for
you to shave your head?
Alright.
- Alright, thank you.
- Jan is--
- So...
- What I respect about Jan is
that he's a man of his word.
We made a bet to shave his
head for a hundred bucks.
He said, when you get to
Helsinki, we will take care of it.
So, I'm going to pull
out my hundred dollars.
(audience cheers)
- [Jan] Alright, so I
remove my microphone.
- [Gary] Here you go, my friend.
- Well, it's done yet, is it?
- Well, go ahead, here you go.
- That's for you.
- Alright, thank you.
- Go ahead, put that on.
- Thank you.
- It's a real hundred dollar bill.
- [Man] We didn't even get euros?
- Not even a euro.
- [Jan] Well, I'm going to
excuse myself and you can--
- I've never shaved a
man's head before, so...
I hope this doesn't hurt you.
(chuckles)
Good?
- Don't worry--
- Alright, I'm going to
do the first cut, then,
I'm going to move you on
over, give the keynote
'cause that's what you're here for, but.
Are you ready?
- Yes.
- Let's clap it up for this gentleman.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hello, D-Rock.
(clippers buzz)
- [Man] Yeah!
Yeah, whoo!
- This is actually fun.
Just do a little more.
- Don't post it anywhere.
(audience laughs)
(audience murmurs)
- This is fucking awesome.
(audience laughs)
Alright, that's good,
let's clap it up for him.
(audience applauds)
You're a real sport, you look great.
- Yeah?
- Great.
- Good morning.
- [Man] Morning.
- So, the format that we've
set up here is I'm going to
give a 20 to 30 minute, kind
of, 20 or so minute keynote
and then, I'm going to open
up for about 20, 25 minutes
of Q and A and so, the
thing that I really wanted
to talk about this morning was
a couple of different pillars
that I'm seeing in the
marketplace that I think will help
the individuals in this room
and I think the word that
I want to focus on most of all
this morning is practicality.
I think, when I think about
the makeup of the individuals
in this room, whether they come
from a corporate environment
or in a startup an entrepreneur,
two years into their business,
20 years into their business,
I think the thing that
really resonates with me is,
especially at this point in
the evolution of the internet,
which is really what we're
all kind of sitting here
and talking about,
there's a really interesting
delta of the people
in this audience, in this
market of Helsinki, in Europe,
the U.S., mainland China,
the people that are clearly
accelerating are the ones that understand
the practicality of the moment.
Not where Blockchain is going,
not what television commercials
used to do for them,
but who's actually marketing
and executing in a May/June
2018 world and taking
advantage of where all of our
collective attention is
and what to do with it
based on their business objectives today
and within the short term.
And so, for me, the thing
that's most interesting is that
in a world where things like Ai and AR
and the emerging Blockchains
that I think are going to be
built in the next couple of
years and in a world of voice,
which I'm unbelievably
passionate about and really,
I do think that the apps
built on top of Alexa
and Google Home, Apple Pod
are, no question, going to have
the same impact on our
society the way that Waze,
or Spotify, or Shopify,
or Instagram has as apps
on top of the iPhone.
In that whole world, to me,
that feels like 12, 24, 36,
48, 60 months from where
it starts making an impact.
To me, if I have any impact
on this audience today,
the places where I want
to go on or where I think
you can have the biggest return
on what you're trying to do.
Regardless of what you're
doing, whether you're developing
an incredibly large project
that you're working on,
whether you're selling
sneakers, whether it's T-shirts,
or your services, whether
you're a SaaS company,
a media company, no matter
what anybody does here,
running for mayor, no matter
the currency is attention.
The currency that we all
strive for is attention.
And then, once you have the
attention, the game that we all
need to play is the ability to
create words in written form,
audio, video, or pictures
to inspire an action
that we're intrigued by.
For me, that plays out very simply.
When I look at the landscape today,
this is the remote
control and the platform
of our attention.
And when you look at the data
of how much time is spent
on YouTube, and Facebook,
and Twitter, and Instagram,
and LinkedIn on this device,
social networks or content
platforms that we now call
social networks represent
almost half the time
humans spend on a cell phone.
I think we can all agree
that the amount of time
that we spend on a cell
phone is staggering
and continues to grow.
For me, if you are not producing
audio, written words, videos and pictures
for those seven to eight
platforms today, on a daily basis,
consistently, you are
on the beginning process
of complete irrelevance in our society.
And for me, not having a
complete religion around that
is a grave, grave mistake.
The other thing that becomes
unbelievably interesting
for me this morning at this
keynote is the fact that
in this market, Helsinki,
Finland, and the Nordics,
as a whole, the two platforms
that I obsess the most over
today for scale, Facebook
and Instagram, the ads,
the influencer marketing
market and the organic reach
are all dramatically more
interesting in this market
than they are in other parts of Europe,
definitely than they are
in the U.S. and Canada
and other parts of South America.
If I could really get you
to a very simple place
this morning, the only thing
you actually, fundamentally
have to understand is that Facebook ads,
both in Instagram and
Facebook form, in this market,
are so under-priced that
even if you are average
at the creative that you
put behind those ads,
you will get disproportionate
return on your business
whether you're B2B or B2C.
To me, that is a moment
that I haven't seen
since early Google.
When I think about my career,
when I launched an e-commerce
wine business in 1996,
I was able to build a
business that was doing
three million dollars a
year on 10% gross profit.
So, $300,000, before expenses,
a business of that size
with a $14,000 a year
marketing budget in year
one, I was able to build
that business from a three to
a 60 million dollar business
in five years, 100% on the back
of email and Google AdWords.
When I look back at that
story, I have enormous amounts
of regret because I genuinely
believe that should have been
three to 200 million dollars.
The mistake I made in my
youth, the mistake I made
that many people made was
I just didn't understand
how good of a deal Google
AdWords were from 2000 to 2004.
They were so remarkably under-priced
that I wasn't able to quantify,
especially since I had
no prior experience, that I
was buying beachfront property,
that I was digging up gold
at enormously low prices.
That underlining
understanding, in hindsight,
is what drives me this
morning to suffocate
anybody's excuses in this
room to why Facebook,
to why Instagram doesn't work.
Or for the people, actually, watch this,
how many people here have run Facebook ads
and it didn't, for-say,
work as well as you wanted?
Which, I'm sure is for
a lot, raise your hands.
Actually, raise them high,
please, I want to see this.
So, I think this is
what's super important.
There's an enormous
percentage of people here
who've already done what
I'm spitting as the thing
you need to be doing.
But I want to make sure
that 20% of this room
that just raised their hand understood
that there's so many variables
that go into something
not being successfully, most
of all, the biggest variable is
you probably did not do a good
job executing the campaign.
At the end of the day, when you
think about ROI of something
the ROI of anything is always
far greater for the people
that are good at it versus bad at it.
The ROI of a piano for me is zero.
The ROI of a piano for Elton
John is over a billion dollars.
So, to me, the concern I
have is that we're sitting,
right now, in this prime era
where everybody in this room,
and I mean everybody,
government employees down to
entrepreneurs selling
a tie on the internet,
all have unbelievable
white space in this medium
and I believe that there's
a gross misunderstanding.
And I challenge and predict
that everybody in this room
that doesn't run a hefty amount
of Facebook ads, Instagram ads,
and Instagram influencer campaigns
during this next 24 to 36 months
will look back at this speech and this era
with the same regret that
I have through my body
to what I did from 2001 to 2004.
Which is, you may win and do quite well
but, please, don't misunderstand it,
you've left an enormous
opportunity on the table.
It's so funny, in the U.S.,
I've been pontificating this
for about three or four
years and, by the way,
just for those who are scoring at home,
the cost of the CPM on Facebook
has gone up substantially
in the last 24 to 36 months
globally and, definitely,
in the U.S., yet, still
grossly less than it deserves.
It's interesting, I pontificate
this and big companies see,
wow, let's clap it up,
this is fucking clean.
(audience applauds)
(laughs)
- [Jan] Alright, thank you, guys.
I'll be back a little bit later.
- In the U.S., I have the
biggest COs in the world
arguing to me that this platform
doesn't sell their product,
that Facebook's not ROI positive,
meanwhile, in the other
side of their mouth,
they're complaining to me
that it's bringing down
the American democracy
and things of that nature.
I mean, you're talking
about a platform that is so
fundamentally powerful,
that the CEO of the company
had to present in front of
congress over a two-day period
on it's impact on the
psychology of the end consumer.
This is not,
this is not a platform that everybody here
should be underestimating.
I would argue, including
me, who is, no question,
one of its biggest
cheerleaders, everybody,
everybody at this conference
is underestimating it.
So, first and foremost, very simply,
in a very practical way,
taking a step back and
understanding what's happening
for real, on Facebook for real,
in both its media capabilities
and its creative capabilities
is something I implore
everybody here to do.
As far as practicality,
the other thing that I want
to really talk about is how remarkable
this era actually is.
In a macro, we are living
through what is now
a 20, 25 year invention in our society.
As much as we underestimate Facebook,
I believe the we underestimate
the internet as a whole
dramatically more.
Everything is being played
out on top of this platform.
And, for me, how many people
here are entrepreneurs
or startups, raise your hands.
Amazing.
So, for me,
one of the biggest things
that I want to talk about
is the ecosystem at this
moment around this platform.
Meaning, it's never been more practical
to actually make money in a world where,
one more time, hands.
Startups, entrepreneurs.
In a world where all of
us over the last decade
have been pushed enormous
propaganda around raising money
and me watching as, you know,
I made my first investment
in 2007, my first three
investments were Facebook,
Twitter and Tumblr and,
as you could imagine,
that worked out tremendously well for me.
But it's interesting
to see what's happened
in the 11 years since.
In invested in Tumblr after
it had tens of millions
of users in it's B round at a
14 million dollar valuation.
Now, based on a lot of your
reactions to that statement,
as you know, in your
idea phase, as the seed,
in the U.S., companies are able to get
four to 10 million dollars valuation.
The insanity and borderline
fraud that is going on
with ICOs in the crypto
world, I mean, this is just
a completely non practical,
10 years of global
economic growth, broken
landscape that absolutely
has nothing grounded in
practicality, I want to remind
everybody in this room, when
you're building a startup,
you're building a business,
not a financial arbitrage
machine that has to hit
web economic data points
of raise your next round
based on users and all
this other horseshit
that VC propaganda has
pumped into the system
for their selfish points of
view and what they're doing.
And, by the way, I'm a
capitalist, I love all the VCs,
I am a VC but I need the
founders and startups in here
to understand their business
model because their advice
is predicated on what they
need to be doing for themselves
and their shareholders, not
for what they should be doing
for you and, more
importantly, the VC landscape
is littered with, at its best, has-beens
and people that have never
done it and the advice lacks
the practicality of the
current landscape and so,
I hope everybody heard me very clearly
and when you re-read the transcript,
I have no problem with people
that are deploying capital.
As somebody who's on the other
end of emails like the one
I got the other day when
somebody who lost $300,000
of my hard-earned money
said it was no big deal
and he was glad that he
learned and I was like,
"That's nice that you learned, fuckface,
but you lost my money."
There are both sides of the
ecosystem that are at fault,
both founders and VCs,
right now, lack practicality
in a 2018 world because
the world is too flush
with money and many of you
in here are not actually
building businesses, you're
building a house of cards
that falls the second there's
any economic slow down
or an algorithm change
by one of the platforms
that you're actually building
your company on top of.
So, again, and very much
my hope this morning
where the Q and A goes,
as I try to navigate
through Jan's hair,
I hope that what I can put in the ground
is what has serviced me super
well for the last 20 years
and will for the next 30 years which is,
are you grounded in practicality?
Do you actually live
and navigate in the year
that you actually live in?
Are you factoring in
enormous economic prosperity
for a decade and when does that go away?
Are you factoring in that
you're building your business
on top of somebody else?
One of my favorite things
that's going on right now,
back to building on top of somebody else,
is how many people complain,
how many people six or 12
months ago started seeing
their friends or startups
complain about Instagram or
Facebook's algorithm change?
And I would sit there and I
would laugh as people would
cry about this and I would
remind them and I remind you,
Helsinki, this morning,
those platforms are free.
The platforms are free.
All the people that are
complaining that they're not
getting as many likes, or
engagement, or the organic reach
went down need to be reminded
that you built your content
on these platforms.
You built something on the free attention
that these platforms had.
You selfishly took that
attention for your interest
and then, when it started to
decline at the cost of free,
you got fucking pissed.
That makes no sense, practically.
And so, if you're building
your business on top
of another company, and you're
getting the benefits of it
for free, take the goods while
the good are being given.
Take that data and then make it your own,
build your first party
ecosystem around that
and then move on your
merry way but, definitely,
don't be at the reliance of the platform.
There are many people here
who will continue to navigate
off that free and then be
caught and I just am struggling,
and actually, that's a
good way to set this up,
I'm struggling with the lack
of practicality and naïveté
in our ecosystem about
what's going to happen.
My favorite day, recently,
in the tech world was
when Amazon and America
bought Whole Foods, a large food retailer.
Everybody was stunned.
Like, shocked.
Like, all the big CPG companies,
the Coca-Colas, the Pepsis, the Quakers,
the Campbell Soups of the
world, all of a sudden,
who were poo-pooing Amazon
for only representing
1% of their business,
now, had a new problem
because they owned one of
the most important retailers
and I read all the comments,
and I read all my emails,
and I just watched the world,
in that world react to it
and I was taken aback by people's naïveté
as if we don't understand
what's happening here.
Guys, do you understand that
Apple could buy every company
that you think is awesome?
Multiple times over.
I don't think people
understand what the Alibabas,
and the Tencents, and the
Amazons, and the Apples,
and the Googles, and the
Facebooks are about to do.
Their going to buy the full stack.
When you wake up and you see
that Alibaba bought Tesco,
or when Facebook buys Target,
like, this is where it's going.
And so, again, the framework
that I'm trying to create
this morning is one very
simple thing which is
this has just started.
The internet's the middle man.
The internet's the middle
man and there's seven to 10
companies in the world, globally,
who've been able to build
the layer directly on top
of the internet.
They've won.
Our jobs, all here, is to be
the next layer after that.
The people in this room that
understand how to navigate
Amazon, and Apple, and
Google, and Tencent,
and Facebook best, in a
world where you extract
the value from it before it
extracts the value from you,
will be the individuals
that are most successful.
And so, the reason I'm
building this framework is
knowing that I'm going to have
a lot of time with Q and A,
and when we get to Q and
A, please ask me an basic,
very needle-in-a-haystack
question, that's what I'm here for
but what I'm trying to do this
morning is get everybody's
mindset into what's
actually happening here.
And what's actually happening
here is Uber, and Amazon,
and Airbnb, they're the preview,
they're not the anomaly.
Every industry that every
one of us are in is on-call.
And the internet is lurking.
And somebody and something
is going to attack
where we're doing our thing.
And so, that leads me to
the place that matters
to me the most.
In a world where you're
like, okay, if you believe
what I'm saying, if it makes sense to you,
the question becomes, now what?
And the now what of all of this
gets to a very interesting
place which is the following.
The number one thing that
I would implore everybody
to be thinking about in
this room is your brand.
The reason your brand matters so much
is it's the most ownable asset.
It's also the thing that
will protect you the most
over the next 20, 30 years.
Let me explain.
One of my biggest theses
at this point, right now,
is that voice is going to be
a fundamentally, game-changing
technology for all of us
because we all value time
over almost everything
else, besides our health.
Everybody here that, now,
takes out their phone
to do many actions, will
be doing it directly
from their lips to not a
device like an Alexa pod
or things of that nature
but to the integration of
speakers in our everyday life.
For example, all of you that
are wearing clothes today,
whether it's a tie or a shirt,
it's a very highly likely
world where there'll be
voice activated capabilities
in those products, or in
your ear, or your earpods,
or wherever it may go.
The friction between you
saying something, like,
there's information you
want or a transaction
that you want to create, and
the ability for that to happen,
is going to be almost zero.
When that happens, there are many things
that are in trouble.
First of all, and foremost,
the reason Google has to
win this game is that Google
text search is in deep shit.
The days of you going to
your phone and typing in
a search query a decade from
today are going to be over
'cause it's going to take
you longer than saying,
who was the president in 1967,
how many miles before this,
is my restaurant open and, I'm sure,
how many of you saw the
Google Assistant demo
a couple of weeks ago,
just raise your hands.
That's some crazy fucking shit.
And that's today's technology.
Where do you think that's going?
So, in a world of voice that
I think is going to eat up
buying decisions, are you
in a place where when I say,
"Alexa, get me a black car
or Alexa, get me an Uber",
that becomes a very
interesting conversation.
In a world where we know Kleenex or Xerox
or things of that nature,
they've won this game.
If you tell Alexa to
send you a pair of jeans,
Amazon is going to have the leverage.
They're either going to
send you a private label
or they're going to make a
brand pay through the nose
to be the default jeans
to all of our language.
The number one thing that
will protect your business
over the next decade is building a brand
around your business.
Building a brand that
transcends all the advancements
that we're about to make in technology
that eliminate friction from
the decision-making process.
We've gone from the Yellow
Pages or any directory
that you had in this
country to Google and, next,
it's going to play out in
voice and I wouldn't bet
against Amazon, and when
you think about Amazon
as a retailer, that becomes
unbelievably dangerous.
One could be sitting
here and say, fine, Gary,
but I'm not in the consumer
space, I'm in the B2B space,
which is great but I promise
you, the way that many
will pick their lawyer,
pick their contractor,
their I.T. developer, will be
the same way they do today,
which is through utility
based search or word of mouth.
Both, which will play out in voice.
Both, that will require
everybody here to create brand.
And so, where am I going with this?
Here's where I'm going,
there are way too many people
in this room that are
over-reliant on math.
They are in the sales business,
not the marketing business.
The way they succeed is
through the digital age
of transaction and they
look at things like KAK
and LTV and quant-based
metrics and that's great
and incredible to get you to a point.
But the point of my existence
in the marketing landscape
and where I see all the
opportunity going forward
has far more to do about brand.
There are very few people
here that are thinking about
how to spend five to 25,000 dollars
to make a video that's
two to three minutes long
that tells the story, emotionally,
about what they're doing
and then thinking about how
to distribute that content
in a Facebook and Instagram
world for another $20,000.
The amount of people here who
are willing to roll the dice
on $50,000 on a video on
Facebook to make their world work
is quite low.
It's high risk.
It's not as measurable.
And it's something that most
people aren't investing in.
At the same token, I personally
believe that's exactly
what people need to be
investing in right now
'cause at the end of this
war, which is what it is,
don't get confused of
what Apple, and Facebook,
and Google, and Tencent,
and Alibaba, this war
where you're going to
see more walls put up,
not sharing data, that's
where all the money is,
this war, what's going to happen is
our worlds are going to become
unbelievably frictionless
and we're going to be doing
things that are completely
predicated on brand.
The number one way for
you to get ready for that
because I'm not interested in
telling you what's going to
happen in seven, or nine, or 13 years,
'cause that is totally not practical.
The quickest way for you
to understand that world
is for you to, right now,
become a practitioner
of Facebook advertising
and Instagram advertising
in this market or any market
that you're marketing in
outside of mainland China and Russia.
You have to,
have to become a practitioner
of influencer marketing,
of Facebook media spend, of
creative in these platforms.
The outsourcing and relying on others
in social media marketing
is the mass vulnerability
of this collective room.
Being a headline reader
versus a practitioner
is the thing I'm most
worried about in this room.
Do you know how many people
in this room have opinions
about Facebook, and Twitter,
and Snapchat, and Instagram,
and their add product
and their capabilities
to move their business
without every running an ad
on the platform?
My friends, it's almost 2019,
like, the days of putting
your head in the ground
and hoping this isn't happening,
or having a very basic
point of view on these
platforms is coming to an end.
You've been able to get
away with kind of knowing
about the capabilities,
I do not believe that we
have the luxury of that.
And because of that,
and then we'll go into Q and
A, Jan, I see you hovering.
Because of that, for the 30% of people
that raised their hand
earlier of being entrepreneurs
or startups, because of that,
this is the greatest era
to be an entrepreneur or startup ever.
Because the rules are so
extreme that the incumbents,
people that have been successful,
don't have the leverage that
they have historically had
because infrastructure costs
were deployed against a world
that doesn't exist anymore.
You have to understand that.
The advantages that Bruce, and
I, and others have been able
to succeed in, those values are
not as valuable as they were
if were navigating 50 years
ago because the property
we owned, or the media we
owned, it was more valuable.
The speed in which your
attention is moving in to where
is remarkable and the reason you're seeing
such incredible change,
politically, at a geo level,
and emotionally, and the issues
that we're facing as humans
and talking about, whether
it's racism or sexism,
or nationalism, is happening
strictly because of this.
Because, as a boy that was
born in the Soviet Union,
I'm unbelievably aware of
what propaganda and media do.
We're all becoming a hell
of a lot more aware of it.
The fact that you have fundamental control
at incredibly low cost to do that
for your selfish business ambitions
with all good intentions,
it's nice to build a business,
it's great, the fact
that you can do it too
and you're not taking
full advantage of it,
is the great miss of your life.
Thank you.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Alright, alright.
So, it's time for Q and A.
- Okay.
- And for this year,
we're going to start--
- [Woman] Tell me, Obi-Wan Kenobi--
- We're not gonna go straight to audience,
we actually have people
from, I don't know,
future, past, and we're
going to have them appear
on the screen and they're
going to ask the question, so.
Can we get the first question, please?
Let's see what's going to happen.
(electricity buzzes)
- [Woman] Help me, Obi-Wan Kenobi.
(laughs)
You are my only hope.
(electricity buzzes)
Excuse me, sir,
I was traveling across the
galaxies to find the one.
Can you help me?
- Yes.
- Oh, that's me?
- [Gary] Shit, sorry, yes, I can--
- [Woman] R2-D2, bring me back.
- Oh, she's gone.
- I love it.
- Alright, that was quick one.
Do we have another question
and not Star Wars interrupters?
(electricity buzzes)
- [Alexei] Oh, hi there.
My name is Alexei Habarki and I'm here
to ask you a question, Gary.
So, my question for you
is what is the next thing
that marketers will ruin?
- Huh.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
So, I often talk about marketers
ruin everything, right.
My career is trying to figure
out where you're spending
your time organically, and
then, I'm trying to figure out
how to penetrate it and sell shit.
And so, I think the thing that,
you know, there's nothing that's
very black and white to me
but if you look at email, the
reason we've all protected
our text messages so much
is we gave up our email
and marketers ruined it, right.
I think that the next thing
will clearly be voice.
But, I think, what we've
learned from Facebook is,
the great misunderstanding
of Facebook's era
is that the algorithm changes
because the only asset
Facebook is your attention
and as soon as they see that
they're putting too much ads
or things that you don't want,
they start eliminating
it to keep you there.
I think that has changed
my historic point of view
on marketers ruin everything.
I think everybody here is
starting to intuitively understand
that through marketing, we
need to bring more value.
It's less about interrupting
and being selfish
and it's more about bringing value.
But to answer it directly,
I think the voice space
is going to be the big
battle ground where we'll get
a lot of value and then,
marketers will come in
and try to figure out how to
get our attention and buy shit.
- It's like you're going to
ask Alexa or something, first,
going to give you an ad before
it gives you the answer.
- I don't know if, I don't
think Amazon's going to give us
an ad, I don't think when
Bruce says, hey, I want some
toilet paper or toothpaste
that Amazon's right move
is saying, Bruce, you
should try the new Crest.
Nobody's going to want that.
I think where Amazon has
unbelievable leverage
is when he says, I want
three tubes of toothpaste,
they're gonna just send
whatever the fuck they want.
Because I think the thing
that you'll be stunned by
is there's very few things
that you actually very much
care about to stay on the same brand.
And everybody's different.
Somebody in the audience here
may only use this one shampoo,
others won't.
I...
Is this the pair?
Yeah, so, I can't believe
that I bought three pairs
of jeans on Amazon
without saying the brand.
I thought I cared about the
brands of jeans that I wore but,
in the moment, as my behavior's changing,
I was taught by myself
that it's not a category
where I care versus cereal.
I would never say to Google:
Google send me some cereal.
I'm going to say, send me
fucking Captain Crunch.
So, I think it's going
to be interesting to see
where it goes, but I don't
think it's going to be an ad,
I think it's going to be
the leverage of sending
whatever you want.
The blue bar at the to of Google
is not going to be suggestions anymore,
it's where you're going to go.
And, as you can image, that's
going to be very expensive.
- [Jan] Alright, thank you.
Next question, please.
(electricity buzzes)
- Hi Gary, nice to meet you.
My name is Benoit, I'm from France.
I live and work here in Finland
for a project called Marco,
a club for foodie.
Very glad to meet you.
I have a question for you, Gary.
I was wondering, do you
believe in teleportation?
(scoffs)
- Uh, no.
(audience laughs)
I mean, the reality is is
that, I like to talk about
shit that I know.
I have no knowledge or
expertise in teleportation,
so, the answer is no, my
friend, but I like your shirt.
(laughs)
- Okay, thank you for the--
- Oh, wow.
(laughs)
- That's great.
(electricity buzzes)
- Okay.
- Okay, bye-bye, Benoit.
- Are you somewhere here?
Oh, over here.
- You wore the same shirt?
(laughs)
- He loved that.
(chuckles)
One more here or we go to the audience?
- We have couple more.
- Okay.
- Hi Gary, hi Arctic 15.
(laughs)
My name's Matthew Manetta,
I'm an entrepreneur
living up here in the
Nordics from the states
and I have a question for you.
So, what are the three
main points you look for
in a project before you
devote time and money into it?
- So, this has been an
interesting transition,
thanks for the question.
My biggest, so, early
on, I wasn't an investor.
I invested in those three
very successful companies,
then, I started getting
high on my own supply
and thought I was special
because of those three bets
and I became an investor.
In hindsight, the very
obvious mistake I made is
I've had a good entrepreneurial
career, I'm an operator.
I'm probably even more
a COO than I am a CEO,
if you really look under
the hood of how I navigate.
So, the biggest mistake that I made was
I would look at a business
and I believed in the thesis
and I would invest in it
because I knew what I would do.
But what I didn't take
into account was that
the entrepreneur or the CO,
that she or he wasn't capable
of doing what I would do.
So, in today's world,
and I invest very rarely,
'cause I think everything is
overvalued and I'm just kind of
waiting for the next
cycle, but once in a while.
Robin Shapiro walked into
my office, she blew me away
with her concept on cricket protein.
So, I did some homework on it,
she was unbelievably passionate,
I believed in the thesis
that cricket, as a protein,
as a food source, has a lot of upside.
Then, I spent a lot of time asking myself,
do I believe she was
in it for the long haul
and could she move the
company into a totally
different space if it didn't work out.
I am, now, at the point, to
answer the question directly,
51% of my energy is based on
do I believe in her, or him
to be able to win, the jockey,
49% on the horse, then away I go.
I have to fall in love with the person.
I prefer, at this point,
to mitigate my risk,
so I'd love to invest in
somebody who has done it before,
so I can look under the
hood of how they did it.
And then, of course, have
to believe in the thesis.
Like, no question, I can
already feel and you could see
from the talk this morning that the apps
that are going to be built on
top of Alexa and Google Home
is going to be a place where
I do a lot of investing.
And so, the jockey and the
horse, only those two variables.
- [Jan] Okay.
- I'm not worried about
could Google copy this,
or Facebook beat this, competition
doesn't factor in at all.
I definitely don't want
to see your bullshit math,
metrics of in three years
we'll be doing 28 million,
it's straight, black magic bullshit,
bullshit, bullshit.
Like, fucking bullshit.
(laughs)
Sorry, I mean, just like--
- [Jan] Bullshit!
- Business school
dynamics in a 30 page deck
based on the reality of business is like
fucking outer space,
it's like teleportation.
(audience laughs)
So, the jockey and the horse.
- [Jan] Okay, good.
Oh, Matt's still there.
- Hi Gary, hi Arctic 15.
- Next one.
- My name's Matthew Manetta.
I'm an entrepreneur living
up here in the Nordics--
- [Gary] I know, Matthew, you
already asked your question,
dick, get off the stage.
(audience laughs)
- [Jan] Next one, please.
It's modern technology.
- I get it.
- Before you devote
time and money into it?
- [Gary] Alright, Matthew,
what I look for is the--
I'm just kidding.
(laughs)
Can we go into the audience?
- [Jan] I think we have one
or two more good ones coming.
- Okay.
- Yep.
- Hello, Gary, I am Roman
from Estonia but I've lived
all over the world and I
have a question for you.
Is there any business area that
you would never invest into?
(sighs)
- Yeah, I mean,
I don't think it's a good idea...
(stammers)
This is where it's a little
tough, I don't know if he means
geographically or in genres of business.
- Genres.
- Genres?
- [Jan] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't
invest in things that I think
were passed by.
So, I would never invest in
search engines that are print
and written based, based
on what I just said.
I don't think it's a
good idea to invest in
retail companies that have
too much of their capital
tied up in their locations in
a world where e-commerce is,
no question, generating disruption.
I mean, the actual answer to this question
as I'm going through my mind
is actually a ton of shit.
I think in a world that
we're living in right now
where technology is sweeping our lives,
it makes so many areas vulnerable.
So, to me, I probably spend a lot of time
eliminating things and
I think there's probably
way, way, way more things I
wouldn't invest in anymore.
I mean, I wouldn't invest
in a social network now.
It's just so hard to penetrate
in a world where Facebook
and the incumbents.
I think we all saw what
happened with Snapchat.
Enormous growth, in essence
ended up being a feature
and now has to innovate to succeed.
So, my answer is, most
things I wouldn't invest in
because I think they're getting
disrupted too aggressively.
- [Jan] Okay, thank you.
Thank you, Roman.
- Thank you, Gary, that
was a good answer, bye.
(laughs)
- Way to guess, Roman.
(electricity buzzes)
- Oh.
- There we go.
- [Man] Oh, hello, how's everybody doing?
I was reading this amazing
book by you-know-who
and I had one question for you guys.
Actually, this one goes to Jan.
Jan, how's your hair?
(laughs)
- [Jan] Oh, it's pretty awesome.
(loud slap)
Oop.
(laughs)
- [Gary] Nice work, Jan.
Thank you.
- [Jan] I think you have one
more left from the future
or the past, let's see.
(electricity buzzes)
- Hi Gary, my name's Jonathan Herchon
and this blur that you see across my face
is actually deliberate, there's
no technical problem here.
It's just that I'm kind of
famous for the fact that
there are no pictures of me
on the internet and I would,
very much, like to keep it that way.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- So, my question for you is this.
We're both from Silicon
Valley and we're both here
in the Nordics and I've been
involved in public relations
for 20 years in the tech
scene and I've been working
with a lot of different Nordic
companies over the years
and I'm actually very
surprised that more people
in Silicon Valley don't
know about the Nordic tech
evolution and the fact
that we actually have
great technology up here.
So, my question to you is this:
Why do you think more people
in Silicon Valley don't invest
in Nordic companies and
how can that be changed?
- Thank you, my friend.
I think America has an
enormous America bias.
I think Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs live in a bubble.
America is unbelievably not
global, it's quite insularly
and I think that there's
friction in location
and cultures that they don't
think they need to deal with
because there's an abundance
of opportunity within the U.S.
in the same way that I think
you'll watch over the next
hundred years China do very much the same.
The market's so big,
there's no reason to address
other markets, and so, I
think that's the reason.
And that's why I really get upset
about the VC pedestal Silicon Valley thing
'cause there's so many
great entrepreneurs here
whose biggest dream is to
get funded in Silicon Valley
and win that game, where I
feel like that's pandering
to something that is not as
practical as all the opportunity
there is to actually to
build a viable business
in your market or your region.
So, to answer your question, my friend,
I just think it's a U.S. bias
and the U.S. Silicon Valley
investment ecosystem has more
than enough opportunities
within it where they can
fly to Chicago and New York,
or drive down the street
versus having their company
seven hours away.
- Okay, gentleman actually right here.
- That's a great answer, thank
you very much for your time.
Very appreciated.
- Alright, that wraps up
our hologram stuff, so now,
does anybody here have
any question to Gary?
- Let's do it.
- Alright.
- [Jan] Let's do it.
- Hello.
- How are you?
- [Taylor] Good, I've been
listening to your podcast
for the last couple of years, so huge fan.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Taylor] My name is Taylor,
I'm from a company called
Valuer, Valuer Ai, we connect
startups with corporations.
My question's kind of two-fold.
So, you've talked about these
unicorns that are looking into
buying up these other larger
companies and other markets
and basically this unilateral takeover.
- [Gary] Yes, yes.
- [Taylor] How do you
encourage fortune 500 companies
to start figuring out they need
to start shelling out money
now to not be left behind?
- The problem is I'd
yell at them every day.
They don't want to do
the capital expenditure
because it hurts them in a
90 day window on Wall Street
and they are actually very
aware that, often, their culture
is not a good body for
the organ on the outside
that they bring in.
So I think, you know, when
everybody wakes up in three years
and realizes that Unilever
paid a billion dollars
for Dollar Shave Club, and
it failed, it's going to make
Pepsi, and Proctor and
Gamble, and Kelloggs nervous.
On the flip side, you know,
just back to your question,
just so you know, fortune 500s right now,
are unbelievably aggressive
on the M and A front.
There's so much underlining
M and A going on right now.
Like, they've been convinced.
Like, the way you asked your
question, it's happening.
You're going to see an enormous
amount of M and A right now
from the haves and the
have-nots in the digital world.
The problem is 95% are going
to fail because what they do,
you have to understand, you
have to follow the money.
In the same way that I was
like ranting a little bit
about VCs, that's Wall Street.
You've got the biggest
companies in the world
doing everything in their
power to make profit
in every 90 days.
Because the CEO, she and his bonus
and stock equity is tied to it.
Nobody's building businesses,
everybody's pandering
to fucking numbers.
Got it.
- Yeah.
- [Taylor] Second part is, how
do you tel tell the startups,
hey, don't worry about getting absorbed,
this is good for you as opposed
to, hey, I don't want to do
business with the big man
on the block or something?
- That's a good question.
I mean, I think too many
startups, that's ego and audacity,
right, startups think
they have this clever IP
that if they do a deal with Dell or Pepsi,
I usually remind startups
that they're not as good
as they think they are.
I love when startups tell me,
like, Gary, you don't get it,
we developed something that
fucking Facebook doesn't get.
And I take a step back, I'm like,
real quick, just let me
understand this right,
you and two developers
over the last nine months
created some technology
that Facebook and Google
and Apple don't get?
Get the fuck out of here.
And so, I think that
there is way too much ego
in the startup community around
this special IP they have
and they're not doing it at a...
It looks like they're doing
it, not doing it out of fear,
they're not doing it out ego.
- Thank you, Gary, what's
up, Victor from Slovakia.
- [Gary] How are you, Victor?
- I'm great, how about you?
- Very good.
- Nice.
First of all, thanks for
your content inspiring
our community in Slovakia.
So the question is,
imagine you are no-name,
you are just starting, would
you rather focus on one project
or would you try to be
involved on two, three,
at the same time?
Thank you.
- The answer, brother, is both will work.
I mean, the reality is
there's no right answer,
it depend on the skill in here.
For me, in my youth, I
focused on one project.
It was a family business, it worked,
I leaned a lot of things, great.
But, as you probably know
consuming my content,
some of the biggest things
I'm pushing right now
is be very aggressive in your
20s and try a lot of things.
Some people are naturally self-aware
and have a very clear vision.
Others are still trying to figure it out.
I think the answer, if I can
bring value to the most people
here, is if you've 100%
conviction and you know exactly
what you're passionate about
and what you're good about,
well then, go.
But if you have any doubt,
early on, this is where
you can take the most risk.
What most humans do is
start making money and then,
start creating debt or overhead
that puts them into a box.
The beauty of being in your
20s is you don't have money
or stuff, often, and so,
that allows you the freedom
to try shit and during an era like this,
trying shit around Ai, or AR, or crypto,
Blockchain, is a great thing
because you may stumble
on your passion and what you're good at.
So, both can work.
It comes down to the individual.
And let me give you one
other piece of advice,
if you're saying to yourself,
fuck, then what do I do?
You're never going to
know the alternative.
If you go all-in on a
project, you're never going to
be able to figure out, if
you tried other things,
so this is more about being
optimistic or pessimistic
as a human being.
In 10 years, if you
didn't try something else,
even if you're successful
and you're a pessimist,
you're going to make up in
your own mind that if you did
something else, it would've been better.
So, I think this is
about making a decision
and not dwelling or pondering on what if,
'cause what-ifs cripple people.
- Alright, we have time for
one more and then we have
one more thing after that.
Sam, if you're here, come near the stage.
- [Woman] Hi, Gary,
great to have you here.
- Thank you.
- I'm a huge fan.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Woman] You're actually the
voice of my bedside stories.
(laughs)
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Woman] Thanks for the
podcast, I've been listening
for years and we actually
started with my team a podcast,
to start with, to learn
and build a community.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- [Woman] So now, we have
about 300,000 listeners.
- Wow, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- More than you.
- It's quite nice.
- Not more than me but,
fuck, that's a lot.
(laughs)
- [Woman] Thank you.
So now we're building,
what we learned is that,
we started on a female
sexuality and talking about sex
in a humorous way indirectly
and now we learned that
we also need to include the guys.
- Understood.
- So, we're building our--
- And what, before you go any
further, why have you learned
you need to include the guys?
Because you want a bigger
audience or because you feel like
there's things that are missing?
- [Woman] Well, to make the
every day life of people
in relationships better--
- Right, I understand.
- [Woman] We need to include all parties.
- Okay, go ahead.
- [Woman] So we want to build
this and we are building this
digital foreplay with an AR
twist called More and Better.
It's for couples or
people in relationships
and now we have this
audience here in the podcast
and how do we get it to our app?
- Very easily, you throw right hooks.
Like, you basically, I mean you
listen to my podcast, right?
- [Woman] Yep.
- As you know, when I
have things I care about,
whether it's my sneaker,
my book, my voice con,
I will read my own ads in
the beginning of my podcasts
before I go into my podcast.
I think the most interesting
thing that people struggle with
when they've figured
how to build an audience
which is to bring value,
is to then get the gear
to ask that audience for something.
I would have you and whoever
else is part of the show
or whoever is in the show to read ads,
like, before you start
the podcast, you say,
hey, we've got our new app
and before you listen to
the rest of this podcast, it
would mean the world to us
if you go download the app.
And then you just keep on fucking asking.
- [Woman] Keep on fucking
asking, thank you.
- You got it.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- We have run out of time
for the questions part now
but we have a really quick
startup pitch to you.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So, Samsa from Kee-eh-co come on stage
or pitch from the microphone.
Let's do this.
(audience applauds)
- Hey, Gary.
- Come on up, come on.
- What out for Jan's hair.
- Yeah.
- Nice haircut.
Hey Gary, thanks for the chat.
- Hey, how are you?
- Good, good.
- Yeah, I appreciate you
being very vocal about
the voice coming up and
I share the passion.
I'm building a voice
community and, basically,
what I'm thinking here is that,
there's two things in the voice.
There's the complexities of
finding good stuff to listen--
- [Gary] Yes!
- That's all over the place,
then, there's the length
of the content.
- Yes.
- That makes it difficult
to consume on the goal.
And then there's the one
direction idea of it.
There's no conversational
dialogue, so that's what
we are trying to solve, build
a dialogue between people.
We call that mini-cast.
So, what I'm wondering is that do you see
that there's space for my direction
of conversational
service around the voice?
And, if so, shall we
partner or shall we comp it?
(laughs)
- You know what, I think
that's, so I want to,
let's keep going here
'cause I want to make sure
I fully understand.
You want to build a platform
that allows Jan and I
to communicate through voice devices?
- Um, basically, you can
think of it as an Instagram
of voice or Twitter of voice.
You can do your mini-cast
which is short voice
commentary on your phone,
others can reply and comment.
And Ai helps to build
the conversation threads.
- My belief is that that's
going to be more friction
than you realize.
Meaning there's a reason
that we text each other
and don't send each other
voice memos back and forth.
Because it's faster to text.
I think when we communicate
with an Ai voice device
that replies in real time,
that's more of a utility
or it could be entertainment.
I think when it comes to
peer-to-peer communication,
text is faster than voice
which is why we're doing
less phone calls and why
we don't do voice memos.
So, if you asked me, that
wouldn't be the place
that I would first go to
because, if you think of Voxer,
if you think of other things,
there's been other things.
You can layer Ai on top of it.
I'm not so sold that that's
the consumer behavior
that is obvious to me yet.
Now, what may happen is,
as we get sucked into
engaging with voice devices
in an everyday life,
we migrate because we use
it this way with a device,
to the way we talk with
each other, to more voice,
but I feel like that
is a secondary behavior
built on the back of us
interacting with Ai devices,
not the primary thing that
we're going to start with
which would then, make
me believe that what
you're positioning is
seven to 10 years away,
if it even happens, more so
than the thing that I would
believe happens next.
One man's point of view.
- Very quick follow-up.
- Yes.
- So, my point is that,
when we do podcast today,
they are studio productions.
What our claim is tech is
ready that you can do that
from you phone--
- Have you seen Anchor?
- Sure.
- So, I think they're the
ones who are claiming or,
at least, are early in the U.S. market
to be doing that and I'm
watching it very careful,
I'm not an investor or
advisor, I know them
but not really all that
well but I like them.
I do think there's something to that.
I see a lot of my fans when I bring it up
start their podcasts
on this and I do think
there's a space for that, for sure.
- Yeah, exactly, that's
what I believe as well.
- Understood, awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Nice to meet you.
- Alright everybody, let's
take a quick group selfie
to wrap this thing up.
(chuckles)
Can you, a little bit
warm it up and get up
and cheer for us, yes?
Oh shit.
(chuckles)
Alright, thank you.
- [Gary] Helsinki,
thank you for having me.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Jan] If you want Gary to
every come back to Helsinki,
clap a little bit louder please.
(audience cheers)
(slow electronic music)